[Music]
thanks denise in today's eight on your
side aarp has identified the top scams
targeting black communities
we're seeing a number of scams that are
targeting the black community and those
range from government
scams calling up saying that you're
they're the irs or that uh you know we
have your covit 19 stimulus uh money
that we want to give to you but first we
need your personal information we're
seeing lottery scams as well a lot of
romance and dating scams now that more
people are online and using dating
online dating services
shanny hostin of aarp says a recent
survey reveals older black women
reported they were less aware of scams
and fraud making them more vulnerable
and that's why aarp is releasing this
information the survey also showed close
to 60 percent of black adults who have
lost money to a scam have lost money to
more than one scam and the 56 of black
adults have not registered their numbers
to the national do not call registry so
here's what you can do right now sign up
for the national do not call registry
use unique passwords and sign up for
aarp's fraud watch network it is a free
resource that delivers information about
the latest scams right to your inbox you
can call the free helpline number on
your screen that is 1-877-908-3360